all right hello everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-1461 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures sight 6 has been constructed
around a CP 1461 task force lambda 30
whiskey-tango-foxtrot
is on permanent assignment to reinforce
site 6 security any unusual activity
from scp-1461 is to be reported to
on-site level 4 supervisors who will
implement a four seven day break
procedures at their discretion see site
six standard procedures guide any
operatives entering a CP 1461 should be
fitted with full NB c-- a nuclear
biological chemical anomalous protection
and armed escorts scp-1461 is considered
a high-priority target for the
organization known as the Church of the
broken God who have made attempts to
reach site 6 and access scp-1461 since
19th description scp-1461 is an english
manor circa 1890 with attached sub
levels it came to the foundation's
attention on November 1941 when the
dwelling and its sublevel facilities
vanished then rematerialized after an 11
day period of absence the surface
portion of scp-1461 is a two-level
dwelling with 12 bedrooms four baths
three studies a main foyer a ballroom a
library and kitchen and a pantry
basement most of these rooms were
converted into simple barracks prior to
foundation acquisition and are believed
to have been dwellings for the cult site
six staff have reinforced the structure
and used the available space to house
monitoring rooms and security forces no
anomalous activity has
ever originated from the manor itself
the sublevel facilities are accessible
through the Mathers basement the layout
and size of the sublevel facilities has
yet to be accurately measured due to the
anomalous qualities of the facility and
hostile entities within the facility is
constructed primarily from concrete iron
and brass but also a number of exotic
and or unknown materials the layout of
the facility follows illogical routes
and architecture for example doorways
open into solid walls or open chasms
stairwells ascend into empty space etc
extensive damage is apparent throughout
the facility certain sections have caved
in and are filled with an unidentified
grey sandstone that exists nowhere on
the Foundation's expanded periodic table
of elements the facilities also contain
a wide array of anomalous artifacts both
active and neutralized see inventory
report 114 61 current it is unknown
whether the facility's erratic layout
and artifacts were present prior to
scp-1461 s disappearance or if they were
introduced during said absence these
sublevel facilities are extremely
hazardous with an extensive array of
moving mechanical apparatus 'as gear
works Pistons steam pipes and coolant
tubes that lack appropriate safety
measures the machinery is maintained by
strategic placement of nozzles that
dispense a black mucus-like substance
which is highly corrosive to organic
materials but also serves as a coolant
and lubricant some sections appear to be
emitting strong gamma and x-ray
radiation registering 75 counts per
second at their highest recorded reading
the source of this radiation is unknown
as none of the machinery appears to be
constructed with or houses radioactive
components
scp-1461 contains approximately 57
humanoid entities including seven former
foundation personnel designated as
scp-1461 - one these entities through an
unknown process have been augmented with
crude mechanical implants in an as of
yet undiscovered section of scp-1461
each instance of scp-1461 - one has been
uniquely augmented with little
uniformity between them the majority
have been augmented with metallic teeth
and claw-like protrusions on their hands
giving them lethal close quarters combat
ability other augmentations include iron
bolts haphazardly grafted to the
subjects bones severe reinforcements to
the spinal column and replacement of one
or more organs with prosthetic
equivalents scp-1461 - one appears to
possess no higher brain functions or
retain any sense of self acting entirely
on canine levels of instinct and
intelligence instances stick to one or
two unit groups build easily hidden or
defensible nests an attempt to collect
food cannibalized from one another or
from intruding Foundation staff all
instances of scp-1461 - one are
considered extremely hostile it is
theorized that scp-1461 itself may
command scp-1461 - one the speaking-tube
system throughout the facility has been
observed emitting loud metallic shrieks
that cause scp-1461 - one to retreat
from an area in other encounters a
metallic odor identified to be blood
filters through the ventilation system
drawing scp-1461 - one to the marked
location the frequency and accuracy at
which scp-1461 scent marks areas
currently occupied by foundation
personnel suggests some kind of guiding
hostile
intelligence at least four instances of
scp-1461 - one have received additional
augmentation replacing their esophagus
and lungs with a phonograph device
powered by scp-1461 zone motions these
phonographs
emit a constant repeating stream of
speech peppered with religious symbolism
but has provided no clues as to its
creator or purpose
addendum according to records from 1941
the Amanar was owned by a mr. and his
family a World War one veteran mr. t was
injured during the Battle of the Somme
and shipped to a London hospital shortly
before the war's end his experiences
appeared to have had a profound
psychological effect giving him a
nihilistic view of society he
constructed scp-1461 with the intent of
somehow ending or escaping the world
more information can be extrapolated
from his journals recovered from within
scp-1461 which I will now read this is
evidence summary V 2008 - 5
summary of evidence from recovery site
the 2008 - five-day 14 I think it is
important to provide context so future
generations may recognize the urgency of
my endeavor in 1916 I enlisted into his
Majesty's fifth Infantry Division and in
the bloody trenches of Europe
I witnessed proof of humanity's
barbarism and the absence of God wounded
in battle and wallowing in septic mud
the fever fell upon me and with it came
the visions in my nightmares I saw a
great iron worm with jaws like that of a
dragon devouring the fields of Europe it
had no teeth but masses of grinding
gears that tore flesh and stone into
pulp its voice was the roar of falling
artillery its breath the blistering
poison of mustard gas damned souls were
belched into a starless sky like smoke
lost into a cold indifferent void I have
no memory of my conscious actions during
that time but at last I found myself in
a hospital in London they told me the
war was over but the dreams did not
leave I would wake in a cold sweat
filled with purpose hastily I scribbled
down designs that had been burned into
my mind strange and alien architectures
I did not recognize or understand
finally I returned home to my wife and
children
brave Simon and little Simone were a
welcome escape from my fear but my wife
Clarisse took notice shell-shocked she
called it the word on the lips of every
veterans wife for mother I tried to
explain my visions what instilled such
fear in me but she recoiled as if I were
a mere madman huh if only that were the
case the children heeded my warnings
however they were rightly afraid yet
that was not my intent no Simon do not
fear the Beast no simul please do not
cry father will not let you be fed to
the worm the schematics they must be the
secret to stopping the worm I feel a
connection a familiarity that likens
them unto a great metal snare with them
I will cage the beast des 825 so long so
long in my workshops so long in the
belly of my father's home free from
prying eyes working ever building my
wife questions but refuses to listen
only the children he'd only Simon
understand a finer son no father could
want my family's wealth is modest but
the urgency that gives energy to my
limbs also guides my thoughts through
clever accounting I can take advantage
of the working-classes desperation so
many seek work and honest day's wages
that they do not question my motives
some even show curiosity enthralled by
my designs a work Leonardo himself would
envy they say we are more than employer
and labor we are a growing congregation
seers who know the truth with the
enlightened to spur the others forward
we make excellent time they build and
Forge dig and reinforce laying pipes and
wrapping conductors in rubber on the
surface
speak of a Great Depression economic and
social despair below I lay the
foundation for a greater tomorrow but I
smelled the burning breath of the world
it is closed we must hurry day 2398 I
have seen the puppet of the worm a puffy
Austrian who commands power from the
desperate and then their despair they
hurl themselves into the grinding teeth
of the worm and call themselves masters
of a thousand years I see his face in
the newspapers and scream at his empty
hateful eyes but no one listens no one
sees the nightmares have changed now
there are more than mere soldiers on an
apostate battlefield now there are
prisons camps of men and women and
children their flesh shriveled by
cruelty and neglect the worm feeds on
them and their souls are so weak they
cannot even flee into the heavenly sky I
fear for them but I fear for my own
children even more in my dreams I hear
them crying on the battlefield they call
out for God for their mother for their
father
only I can answer day 2567
tonight the vision came I saw the worm
eating the rotten flesh of a dead world
the stars had burned out the Sun bled
into blackness until the only light was
but a flickering candle a torch held
against oblivion no Christian God holds
that torch no pagan worship no
politician or priest I hold the torch I
stand within the snare
built of the iron of the earth and the
blood of man and I baked the worm to its
due day 2568
success the worm is trapped day 2569 my
victory was short-sighted the worm is
caged but it has already unleashed its
plague upon us the bombs fall upon
London war rages once more the worm
cries out from below mocking me even as
it thrashes within its cage the world is
doomed the work crews fear it or maybe
they fear me some want to leave to fight
another pointless war for their homeland
others stand behind me terrified of what
comes for us how how how can we escape
this rotting world and the locusts that
devour it
day 2569 I finally understand the
purpose of my great machine not a cage
an engine a device that de wharfs all
measure of man's science Satan's magic
and God's miracles a machine that will
deliver us from oblivion all it needed
was a heart a burning furnace to power
it how ironic that the worm that
promised my Doom is now the engine that
will drive our salvation the laborers
who heeded my warnings have banded with
me like a cult to its Messiah they
gathered at my feet as a dutiful
Shepherd I will guide them into paradise
some resisted I do not hate them I do
not hate the people of this ruined world
I pity them it was all I could do to
instruct my followers that a merciful
death is preferable to the alternative
those who had not come with us we're
better off sent away by their kin than
by some heartless enemy on the
battlefield
I go to throw the switch of my great
machine and free ourselves for the
madness of the gray
day one in one brilliant flash my engine
and the manner above have been delivered
from the war-torn earth to a new world
this place is like our own but different
in many ways a grey mist swirls around
the Manor free of the stink of gunpowder
and urban decay the Manor sits in a
field of grey soil devoid of vegetation
I hear no buzzing of insects
I see no Sun or moon just a dull
sourceless light a dismal arrival
perhaps but a welcome one I broke wine
with my brothers and sisters today we
are saved the engine has gone quiet
now the worm must have been consumed by
its own fire some merciful part of my
souls so flushed with victory and new
hope praise as the worm is at peace day
- where on earth there would be day and
night here light never changes gray mist
lingers muting all sound my followers
look to me for answers they say I am the
voice of the engine surely I must know
what to do I push for patience and make
promises I already begin to doubt myself
to satisfy their curiosity I asked three
of my bravest to venture out in search
of anything I try to reassure my family
but Clarice looks at me only with fear
and hate
she has Walt herself up in the bedrooms
with Simone Simon stays with me though
he wishes to go out and see this new
world
I refuse him I will not threaten his
life for the sake of knowledge even as I
write these words I am startled by what
I see this world was to be our safe
haven was it not day three the men I
sent into the mist of return thanks to
the lengths of string I provided them no
vegetation no animals no Sun nor stars
no civilization this world is empty and
gray not hell like the world we left
behind a limbo does that make it better
day for the dreams no longer come where
before I could scarcely close my eyes
without envisioning arcane machinery and
prophecies of doom now my mind is empty
and the silence mocks me the food stores
are being rationed I do everything I can
to convince the followers that utopia
will come that this is just a transition
but empty stomachs speak with more
conviction than a prophet without a
prophecy a nurse named Eudora seems to
have taken it upon herself to stir the
hearts of the following but her sermons
cut short as I approached and she
regards me with stony silence until I
withdraw
day five my wife refuses to leave the
bedrooms she does not speak to me
ignores the food I leave for I call for
Simone but they do not come out how have
I come to hate my wife her spite will
not save us two of the younger followers
attempted to steal food from the
kitchens they talk of dwindling food
stores of mistrust of strange noises
coming from below though my great engine
no longer turns if we imprison them the
others would have protested instead I go
to the others and tell them that the
young ones have run out into the fog
intend to find answers not everyone
believes me including Eudora instead
they go back to plotting in quiet I
worry for my flock day six
now everyone speaks of sounds from below
of rattling pipes and grinding gears
though I assure them the machine has
been shut off to assuage their fears I
sent Danvers and Bertil me to
investigate we should hear back from
them sometime later tonight or morning
no one questioned the fresh meat
prepared for dinner day seven my wife is
dead I grew furious at her petulance and
pried open the doors with a pickaxe she
had arranged Simone for bed and then
damn you Clarice you run or I wanted to
save my children Danvers and Bartleby
have not come up the grinding noises
come every hour now louder and louder
the house shakes around us
I fear the worm may not be as dead as I
hoped day 8 darkness is finally fallen
then with it came a terror I have never
known even in the trenches cold seeps in
through the windows strange shadows move
in the fog and I hear what sounds like
footsteps on the rooftop the house
groans in shakes the worm struggles the
courage of my followers phrase they want
to go home they want to be free of this
horror and this damnable grey purgatory
day night
they have taken Simon Eudora rallied the
followers she declared that the worms
spoke to her in her dreams and that she
is the voice now the worm demands
sacrifice she said the son of the man
who trapped it I fought them I fought I
would not let them take my boy the only
thing I have left but there were so many
and they had gorged on the flesh of
their fellows I was but one broken man I
am no Savior no torch in the darkness
just a puppet to my own madness I feel
that every action I have taken every
vision and design i feverishly scrawled
from half-remembered nightmares was
forced upon me by a cruel intellect that
wished to test the limits of my sanity
they have taken Simon below they will
feed him to the worm let this be my
prayer to the starless night to a God
that may not even exist I will not let
it be fed to the worm I will hurl myself
into its teeth that my bones might clog
its innards before I let them take my
son I'm sorry
Clarice
day ten god the noise it's almost
deafening wheels turn and pistons hiss
and from the deepest reaches I hear a
low mournful bellow I have brought my
journal to give my mind something to
focus on as I traverse the machine
looking upon it with my sane eyes I
realize this mazes no work of logic the
tunnels bend and twist without reason
stairwells lead to solid walls and doors
open to gaping chasms the transference
to this gray world may have warped the
machine or maybe I never truly saw it
for what it was and just built according
to my deranged whims I have heard and
seen nothing of Simon or his captors
doubtless their steps are guided by the
same madness that has abandoned me
guiding them with fluid ease towards the
worms waiting jaws I hastened my step
but I seem to be running in blind
circles you have nothing else at least I
have a sturdy in lantern and plenty of
oil from the work crews that toiled down
here
day 11 day and night are meaningless in
this limbo but down here there is even
less measure to the passage of time my
journey has taken me deeper into some
kind of processing Factory these
automated devices gather grace and from
the bare rock heat it into
sickly-looking glass and fill the
created vials with foul-smelling
chemicals I cannot identify against my
better judgement I crept close to
inspect a completed vial and to my
horror a fully formed set of teeth began
to take form another jar held an eyeball
like nothing found in man or nature what
is the purpose of this factory what does
it bill and for whom is this the result
of my design are some mechanical cancer
spread by the worm to twist the machines
function my quarry seems to be in
dispute now I hear them arguing through
the ventilation ducts and empty pipes
Eudora has taken my son deeper leaving
the others behind to harass my progress
or simply abandoning to the whims of the
worm I have my pickaxe and my training
but I must move with stealth I have not
eaten in nearly two days still Eudora's
men still carries strips of meat I also
saw something odd near the lathe room I
have hidden myself within a painting of
exquisite taste it is the work of a
master but I cannot recall when I
purchased it or what possessed me to
leave it down here
the image shares a remarkable likeness
to Clarice smiling as though in happier
times it casts my thoughts that decades
past when I was a different man a
smaller man yet infinitely happier can
knowledge so damn a soul in a universe
of such cosmic evils that I have
witnessed his ignorance truly the only
bliss one can enjoy day 12 my dreams
returned not of prophecy but memory I am
with Simon in the London Museum he pulls
me along eager to see art and history
the beauty of all created by man and God
but I cannot see the beauty I only see
bloody mud and blackened skies the
ugliness of man and a callous God Simon
walks on without paying while I sink
into a bench the day fades away tonight
and I sit in an empty Museum of man's
atrocities the last living thing on a
cold earth overwhelmed by the weight of
it all I wait for death or Oblivion to
take me whichever could stomach so
pitiful a morsel but instead I feel the
presence of another I feel no light from
this beam no warmth yet I sensed that
this was as close to God as any beam
could be it looks like a man but there
is a way to him as those something
greater and stranger were squeezed into
his skin
the child wants and does not know why
the gentleman speaks to me the child
grasps and doesn't know the danger they
burn their fingers and know they are not
ready someday they will be someday they
will give voice to the soul and sing
with the essence of the universe what
gods they will be then what galaxies
they will we with dreams and care but
now they are children and children are
selfish they know only what they want
and then I awoke back inside this
machine on a gray planet so far from the
world of my memories it burdens my bones
just to think of this inevitability but
I force myself to stand just the same
Simon cried out to me I heard him far
below I called back to him but I heard
no reply Eudora's zealots hound me
relentlessly and I fear some horrible
change has come over them in casting
their lot with the worm they speak with
slurred reptilian voices or gargle as
though choking some have even turned on
their fellows as I crept about the
darkness I saw one such rebellion a man
I had tried to lead to paradise fell
upon his companion in an argument over
faith and I felt the heat of his life
blood splash across my astonished face
the teeth gnashing and ripping so big
and sharp like the fangs of a wolf yet
also serrated as the blade of a saw
animal and flesh yet also machine my
surroundings have been affected by the
same mutation rooms I do not recognize
bleed into one another like spill paint
an office with plush green chairs merges
with a warehouse filled with crates that
rattle and bang with some unknown
stinking occupant ladders descended into
pools of viscous liquid that have
flooded what appears to be a school
statues of marble and reliefs of brass
decorate the ceilings and
the very walls rattling belts view
ammunition into neglected piles shells
the size of my head
clattered to the floor in automated
factories producing tools of death I
could not have made this I could not
have wanted such devices and yet here
they stand and always the shriek the
tapping of Heating and Cooling metals
the groan of pressurized hydraulics
I cannot remember what silence sounded
like day thirteen or fourteen Eudora's
followers no longer heed a reason the
demented growl and spit and scavenge for
food their ramblings the stuff of bedlam
others have become something else
feral like lycanthropes of myth they
crawl on all fours their eyes adjusted
to the gloom and shining red twin
pinpoints of demon light I can startle
them with my lantern but they always
return trying to surround me from all
sides
hunters they are and fastest wolves but
their howls are the shriek of tearing
metal Eudora's voice taunts me now it
echoes up through the network of
plumbing from every open ventilation
shaft she announces her glorious
descendants of her devotion to the worm
and I hear true lunacy in her desperate
laughter it ripples through this whole
machine as if she herself is part of it
now I've found respite in a room filled
with hospital beds and windows that look
out into an abyss it reminds me of the
hospital I awoke from the war with him
but I must pry my eyes away from that
dark for my mind cannot tell if I look
into lightless cavern or starless void
Dave 15 I have found you Dora pursued by
her followers made monsters I came upon
a great Cathedral made from organ pipes
marble and the very flesh and bones of
you Dora herself now I see how she could
speak to me through the pipes for her
body has been torn asunder and stitched
upon it her organs are pulled straight
and taut through the tangled plumbing
her skin stretched and inflated with
gases her blood sizzling and steaming
from the hydraulics only her head
remains whole wide-eyed and cackling
seated on the pulpit of this temple to
dementia the monsters refused to set
foot into this hallowed ground
so I alone approached to speak with her
I demanded my son's return but she spat
her own broken teeth at me and said he
had been taken by the worm delivered to
the heart of the machine where its mouth
sat waiting furious I fell upon her with
vengeance tearing what remained of her
body from the brass organs around her
she died screaming and at last was quiet
but then a great bellow interrupted from
the machine and a new voice spoke to me
through the mangled organ I am what you
have made me I am then and I am now I am
choice and I am Turin
I am evil and I am flesh
I am beauty and I am chaos
I am the worm stricken I fell to the
blood-stained floor and wept i cowered
screaming not because of the words that
spoke but that they were spoken with my
voice at last I had beheld the truth I
had tried to bury so deep the worm the
machine the madness that guided my hands
it was me
I am the worm I do not know what
compelled me to stand I did not feel
hope I didn't feel despair like an
automaton I could only move forward to
face Revelation day unknown when I came
upon the core of my great machine I
found my son the machine was not a
weapon
to trap the worm it was not an ark to
carry us to salvation I had sought to
exile myself from a monstrous existence
and then my cowardice and fear I became
a monster I became the worm I built a
shell to hide with him an engine to
spirit me away from the pain the despair
that claimed my Saturday to abandon
creation and gods cold distance but it
would not run without a catalyst
Simon so full of hope and faith so full
of love had dreams how I envied your
strength how I envied your ignorance
ironed to wrap myself up in that
goodness and hide from the world
I threw the switch of my great machine
and it drank the hearts blood from your
lifeless body pumping it into every pipe
and piston I believed your love would
carry us to paradise but it was tainted
by my madness by my active murder I
dreamed of peace then it brought me to
unchanging limbo I demanded paradise but
I deserve only perdition and I was so
horrified by what I had done to you I
could not bear to face it I spoke as if
you were there with me smiled as though
I could see you smiling at me when
Clarice realized what I had done what I
was
she took Simone away before before I
sought her out as well this place is
filled with your memories Simon are they
the last tattered shreds of love you
have for me or are they here to taunt
and punish me as the man beasts that
stalk the hallways surely must be I do
not know if any of you can forgive me
I only know that I promised to save my
son I promised to slay the worm I leave
this journal behind in the hopes that
someday somehow someone will know what I
did and remember the men and women I
damned with my selfishness my fear
I hurl myself into its teeth that my
bones might clog it sinners I am the
world and the hora Boris must eat itself
[Music]
it is believed mad mr. had anywhere from
50 to 100 employees helping him in this
task the majority of whom eventually
reorganized into a cult devoted to
scp-1461 an unknown number of these
followers were present in scp-1461 when
it vanished along with mr. his wife and
two children to date only six of these
individuals have been accounted for
shortly after a CP 1461 rematerialized
unknown individuals entered scp-1461
before foundation agents could contain
the site these individuals are believed
to have been members of mr. fellowship
who had not been present in scp-1461
when it vanished they have successfully
extracted a number of potentially
anomalous artifacts that have yet to be
catalogued or recovered partial list of
cataloged anomalous rooms of the 12th
sublevels discovered by foundation
personnel only 75% of its layout has
been properly mapped and an unknown
number of levels are believed to exist
further below each sub level contains
excavation construction and storage
rooms as well as rooms exhibiting safe
or Euclid level anomalous qualities
and/or artifacts for a full list of
anomalous scp-1461 rooms refer to
document 114 61 current gel production
sublevel 3 an automated factory that
melts down the unidentified gray
sandstone into glass forms them into
canisters and fills them with a green
viscous gel made up of a variety of
exotic chemicals some of these jars
contain fully formed teeth and organs
whose DNA patterns match nothing found
on earth most of the jars have become
inert and their contents have decomposed
the gel production machine itself has
been crushed by a Cavin pipe Hall
sublevel for a hallway lined with
approximately two thousand four hundred
and fifty pipes constructed from brass
iron copper gold bamboo carved Jade and
some kind of substance can clearly be
heard being pumped through the pipes but
their origin and destination are unknown
factory deliveries sublevel 7 a large
unlit warehouse filled with wooden
crates of various sizes
unlike other storage rooms which contain
mundane materials from non-anomalous
sources the crates in this section are
blank or branded simply with factory
deliveries irregular patrols of the
warehouse have revealed that the number
and arrangement of crates changes but as
with the pipe all their origin and
destination are unknown on at least one
occasion muffled vocalizations can be
heard coming from somewhere within the
warehouse but their source was never
discovered
or group sub level 10
speaking to group sublevel 11 the
multitude of brass speaking tubes
connecting scp-1461 appeared to converge
in this room on a large central pulpit
the partial remains of a human female
have been recovered here with evidence
to suggest the body specifically skin
and intestinal organs was used to
perform crude repairs to some of the
damaged tubes catalyst Roux sublevel 12
a large chamber filled with a random
assembly of gears cables pulleys screws
and belts all made of an amalgam of iron
tin gold and other metals some has of
yet-unidentified the Assembly has
suffered extensive damage with evidence
that a large section approximately 12
cubic meters has been violently removed
the location of this section is unknown
an elevated platform is suspended
directly over the assembly the platform
features a metallic bent with the
desiccated remains of a human male that
corpses chest has been pierced by and
large syringes connected to a pumping
machine it's designed suggesting that it
pumped fluid extracted from the syringes
into the missing portion of the
machinery below at regular 45-minute
intervals the assembly attempts to self
start but it's existing damage prevents
initialisation friction heat buildup
eventually results in an emergency
shutdown that lasts until the machinery
is cooled enough to make another attempt
item V 2008 dash 5 was recovered from
the hospital bed
this is a partial transcript of scp-1461
- one phonograph recording I am what you
have made me
I am choice and I am tyranny forgive me
I am then and I am now what gods they
will be that I am evil and I am flesh
I am the trap and I am the trap
I am beauty and I am chaos children are
selfish I am the worm I have broken God
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you very much for listening
if indeed you still are I know some of
you aren't and you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre a shirt Pierce M
Hamlin Muslim Wookiee Jax Merrick
kela born slump God John Oh Porter
captain Gorge Tiber ball cootie tench
cheese whip dips McGee I'm dr. mortis
thank you so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]